WNBA star Brittany Greiner back on
American soil but her Freedom coming
with a big cost the Pentagon fears that
The Merchant of death Biden traded for
her safe return May resume arms
trafficking to some of the world's most
notorious Terror groups Victor Booth
supplied arms to groups like Al Qaeda
the Taliban and Rebels and Rwanda the
cover of today's New York Post sums it
up pretty well with a deal with the
devil he was so bad that D.A agents who
busted him once said this
Victor booed in my eyes
is one of the most dangerous men on the
face of the Earth on the face of the
Earth without a doubt what makes him a
threat to the United States he is a
shadow facilitator he's arming not only
designated terrorist groups Insurgent
groups but he's also arming very
powerful drug trafficking cartels around
the globe
the Democrats don't seem too worried
well he has served most of his term as
my understanding majority of his term
look nobody's doing backflips over here
Dana that he's a free man again he would
have been free in 2029 it's not like he
was serving a life sentence Oh my God
Greg
gshb that's all you have to say before
you say something else glad she's home
but
glad she's home but the deal sucks and
makes us look like suckers gshp that's
all you can say bottom line a good
leader could have solved this if our
leadership wasn't blinded by the
identity variables right they looked at
the box of identity markers for one
person and they looked at the one for
the other and they made a choice they
claimed they didn't make a choice but
there is some kind of evidence that they
had made a choice now they're denying it
so what you had was an intersectional
icon trumping a marine that's a strong
leader and I'm going to go ahead and say
Trump would have gotten both or he would
have said screw you all or he would have
nabbed a Russian abroad and called him a
spy and said okay now we have two for
two something like that as for boot what
if he's instrumental in killing more
Americans or I don't know more
ukrainians or people in general that
trade as bad as it is will only get
worse but this isn't you know it's it's
a good lesson if you're up for a job or
if you're taking hostage
hope that you're non-binary and hope
that you're not just a white male who's
a Marine
judge if Biden has any guts at all
Victor Booth this is what drones are for
well it'll be interesting to see that I
doubt that he's he's going to do that
kind of thing but he this is what I one
of the things I ca I keep going back to
when I said it yesterday there was a
reason Russia wanted this now Russia is
in the middle of a war with the Ukraine
they need Victor Booth Russia is
faltering this war is taking far too
long we had the leverage Russia wanted
him out they need his help and we could
have said no and you know what for Nancy
Pelosi to say oh he would have been out
soon five years without this Merchant of
death who preys on killing Americans and
buying weapons and kills Americans and
even Senator Bob Menendez a Democrat who
highlighted greiner's domestic violence
commit conviction I didn't know that
until he said it said that Russia and
other regimes take American citizens
hostage cannot pretend that there is an
equivalence between brittner Greiner in
the world and Victor Booth nothing can
be further from the truth Chris Wecker
Jessica was on air when this news broke
the former head of the FBI's Criminal
Division who had worked on this case and
he said you'd be hard-pressed to find a
man with more blood on his hands than
Victor Boot and he said he was an
intelligence officer operative for Putin
and now he resumes that career that's
who's free and I can tell you that if
Brittany Griner had served the amount
Victor boot looked pretty damn good
coming out of prison what have you been
there 14 years
yeah it's a shame that he's back on the
streets and it's also a good day for
America that an American prisoner came
home from Russia and to the point about
whether we only care about black
basketball playing lesbians
Joe Biden got Trevor Reed who's a former
Marine out in April Brittany Greiner was
sitting in a Russian prison when that
happened and he got the former Marine
out and Trevor Reed went to Russian
prison in 2018 When Donald Trump was
President same time that Paul Whalen
went and Donald Trump couldn't get him
out of prison but Joe Biden did so if
this is all about celebrity and because
she's an intersectional icon I'm not
buying it a marine came home before
Brittany Greiner and I'm not saying that
this guy should be on the streets it's
obviously an incredibly difficult idea
to wrap your head around letting someone
who has killed so many in her an
American cause back out there but I am
you don't address the trade yeah that's
all well I mean I'm glad she's home but
you're not addressing the trade I just
said it's a horrible thing I also don't
know what you would do I I don't know
you leave someone for another nine years
in a penal colony because you say no you
read it you know what you do you read
the art of the deal Jessica
Christmas reading I got it for you oh
also on tape
for Hanukkah he reads it himself nine
copies well there's there's somewhere in
between letter rot and Moscow and give
up The Merchant of death I think we can
agree on that there's somewhere in
between there now Ukraine has to be
thinking wait a second Joe seriously
You're Gonna Let The Merchant of death
out while we're at war with these guys
not helpful and I'm wondering how
greiner's feeling walking around the
United States right now is her head held
high or is her head hello knowing that
her inner agent are responsible for
springing The Merchant of death out
there in the world and Biden said he did
this because he was under a tremendous
amount of pressure from black women
really
a tremendous amount of pressure from
black women
and he acts like this he's not under any
pressure over the Border he's not any
under any pressure for inflation he's
not under any pressure for anything else
in this ridiculous Administration
but he's under pressure for black women
and he Springs this celebrity out like
that like that 2009 and The Merchant of
death I mean I don't know I mean this
guy not Santa would have left her but
what are you saying I'm saying this if
you have all these sanctions on this
country and if you have all these
weapons that are pouring and killing
these Russians and we have all this oil
under the ground here there's not
something we could have done better to
get a better deal there's not something
hey about how about hey hey Vlad your
little oligarchs yacht that we just
stole we'll give the yacht back how
about we get Waylon and the bullet I
don't think that is
yeah we just have to go now you need
them now because you need them in the
war hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else